dana preno is co-anchor of america's
newsroom co-host of the five and one of
the best people in television she joins
us tonight dana thanks so much for
coming on i'm not going to ask you to
respond to a lot of that script
but
i don't want to put you in a position
alex that was great yeah
but but let's stand back and consider a
president who has not yet completed his
first year in office
and it's not an attack merely an
observation who finds the media
organizations that have cheerlead for
him for two years suddenly talking about
replacing him mid-stream
i don't i've never seen anything like
that before what do you make of it well
it was just last week that the white
house communications team did a little
dog and pony show to the different media
outlets and chastised them for the bad
coverage that they've been getting and
many news outlets actually complied i
remember listening to one npr report
the next morning or two and it was about
inflation and build back better and i i
couldn't believe my ears i almost had to
stop and rewind transcribe it and read
it like alex did because it was like
that good for the biden administration
but this list that cnn did like the
first four people that they name are
already ran for president and lost and
so what does it say about the quality of
their campaigns
the other thing is that the democrats
were pretty much hanging by a thread
until president trump came along and
then they unified in their distaste for
him
but they're trying to run that playbook
again but i think maybe some democrats
and people at cnn are thinking i don't
know if that's going to work the second
time there's two names that are that you
didn't mention that are democrats to
consider i have one disagreement with
you and i have a cliffhanger can i go
through them well i hope you will first
one is governor jared polis of colorado
this is a liberal democrat but he is
also somebody who has been
fearless in talking about covid and this
week he said that's true endemic is the
emergency is over i'm not going to tell
people what they can wear on their face
we are moving on the other thing that
he's done tucker is he's talked about
eliminating the state income tax in
colorado so that that state can remain
competitive so that's different and
fresh thinking and i think the democrats
might want to pay attention to that i
strongly agree with that i wonder though
can i ask you to pause so his line about
you know the co the coveted emergency is
over his politician there are political
considerations behind it but that's
still
not what the atlantic magazine is saying
it's still pretty brave within the
context i'm wondering if democratic
voters are offended by that
well maybe a small portion of them
however if you look at what democrats
found in the exit polling in virginia
what were the what did most of the
independents vote on it was the fact
they were so mad about the schools being
shut down for so long that they were mad
about the way that small businesses were
treated and having to shut down during
the pandemic and the height of the
pandemic when the big box stores like
home depot got to stay open and there's
a deep-seated anger about it and it's
coming out and especially people are
voting with their feet taking their kids
out of schools no that's right that's if
the florida is bulging so really quick
what's the cliffhanger uh the
cliffhanger is um there's just somebody
that you
haven't talked about and that is
sorry to say it's hillary clinton let me
can i read a tweet uh tweet
for you it's also a treat
yeah this is just today okay she said
2024 is a make or break point for the
continuation of american democracy
no one who believes in the power of
voters to choose their leaders and the
continuance of multiracial democracy can
sit this one out and so
could it be a rematch in 2024 like can
america handle it
it wasn't on cnn's list but it probably
should have been sorry i need to take a
break my brain just exploded i you know
as dark as i am in my darkest moments i
couldn't have thought of something like
that and you're a light and cheerful
person it makes me wonder about you a
little bit but think of what alex could
do with that material
it would be amazing for gable news dana
printer thank you great to see you have
a good night everyone hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else